[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to Chicago
the city of Big Shoulders and old
ambition in watch dogs Ubisoft has
created an immersive hyper-connected
playground with new opportunities at
every turn across historic landmarks in
familiar neighborhoods the city is
rendered by a powerful new graphics
engine specially built for watchdogs
rich dynamic lighting weather physics
affect every element of the game world
to create a vivid living City Chicago is
a bustling metropolis with all types and
personalities and watchdogs brings new
life to the countless civilians
populating the city streets each citizen
has a unique identity and reacts
intelligently to the world around them
[Music]
everything and everyone is connected you
can hack into anyone's life tap their
phones their music their accounts
identify criminals disrupt
communications roadways
infiltrate private homes any of these
people could lead to exciting secrets or
unexpected events in watchdog's the
opportunities come to you you have
control over a vast digital network but
remember your choices have consequences
police don't want a vigilante on the
and the media will plaster your image on
the news and if you cross the wrong
citizen you risk a bounty on your head
you may be forced into the darker
corners of Chicago
the city is designed to surprise you any
citizen could be a victim to a killer or
another player lurking inside your game
connection is power and you can use that
against other players in the online
community anyone could be your enemy and
anyone can be watching when I least
expect it watchdogs delivers endless
possibilities challenging players to
observe to discover and to invent new
ways to connect with the world it puts
the power of a city in the palm of your
hand and it begs the question what will
you do that kind of power
you